at the heart of hellblade is our
ambition to sink you into Cena's world
and story to do this it's critical that
we make it as easy as possible for you
to suspend your disbelief one key method
of achieving this is our use of
performance capture
[Music]
what I want to achieve on stage is to
get the best performance and best
storytelling from the actors and then to
get that into the game as Faithfully as
possible I want to see what I saw on
stage in the game this game
when we were shooting the scene from the
Xbox showcase it was quite a zomba mood
on set because that was one of our
moments in the game where it's just
senua just senora and the Furies we have
an opportunity to connect with the
player one-on-one
at this point in Santa's Journey she's
had her confidence eroded there's a lot
of doubt
and she needs to find within herself
a spark of of hope that strength that
she has
in order to continue on
all the grief All the Rage all the fear
everything after
while the scene is relatively simple the
scale and complexity of our performance
capture has multiplied to meet our
creative Ambitions on hellblade 2.
we shot the first hellblade in the
boardroom of our old Studio it was very
MacGyver together in the new studio we
have a custom built mocap space which
has pretty much everything we could have
dreamed of we've got projectors so we
can recreate SATs on the ground if we
need to we've got loads of props that we
have available to us at any time so we
can build sets
[Music]
I remember coming in to interview and
seeing the setup down there and
immediately being impressed by
the clear commitment that had been made
to underpinning great true to life
performance with great quality data so
we've got a lot more cameras this time
around
um they're kind of top of the line at
the moment and in the kind of space that
we have downstairs we have nearly
wall-to-wall coverage which is really
impressive and it's not something that
is common it's certainly a step up from
a few cameras set up in a boardroom
all 42 of our Vicon cameras emit
infrared light and when they hit the
markers on the performers that's
projected straight back at the camera
the tape is retro reflective and
basically as long as three or more
cameras can see that marker they can
triangulate its position within the
volume so when we calibrate
we run around and Define the space in
which the performers can act for the day
and as long as they're within that space
the cameras will pick them up and track
them through the volume the projectors
are really great because they cover
almost the entire floor within this
Green Boundary which is our general safe
volume and what we can do is Project
either unreal or motion build or down
onto the floor to scale which is really
useful for things like scenes with the
Giants where you need something bigger
than the performers as a reference they
can see it move along the floor or we
can set the distance between our props
and pieces of environment to make sure
that that's accurate to the game world
as well
[Music]
the thing that's really cool about this
room in particular is that it's really
purpose Built For Freedom so it's very
soundproofed it's nearly a full Sound
Stage but these points here allow us to
mount a piece of truss to the floor and
then we can get onto the truss on the
ceiling which can carry an insane amount
of weight so if we've got a point here
and a point up on the ceiling we can do
almost any kind of rigging build we can
hang things from the ceiling we can rig
up wire poles any kind of rope work that
we might need this is really useful if
you've got big jumps or swimming that
kind of thing you can get performers up
off the floor and give them the freedom
to move around the space
unencumbered by the floor
with our setup we can push even further
on our ambition of bringing through as
much of our actors performances as
possible into the game even down to the
most nuanced of movements
when you've got a optical system like is
set up and calibrated well you can track
performance movements down to the
millimeter so we can see somebody
shuffling their finger along the table
or just wiggling them very gently you
can see hesitation and breath you know
there's no need to push the action and
overact you can just be your character
I'm here now
what we want is the best performance
possible the best immersion possible for
the player and that's why we go to these
lengths just to try and get that extra
Fidelity of performance into the game
what do you want me to do
as soon as we start getting the visual
performance of our actors as well as
their body data that's when it becomes
performance capture and not just motion
it really just gives a more cohesive and
true to life performance being able to
have the body data that matches the
visual performance it's really all very
in the moment and helps everything feel
much more realistic and just a part of
the whole production
alongside head mounted and motion
capture cameras we're taking a filmic
approach to our cinematics with a
bespoke virtual camera setup
watch this camera in here it gets time
code Jam here and we track this Crown in
relation to this offset marker here so
that we can track the point of the lens
and that allows us to Faithfully track
the camera's lens and look throughout
the scene
with performance capture being at the
heart of our character movement our
props and staging had to facilitate our
vision I don't want to give any spoilers
away but there is going to be a boat in
the game
that boy will have several characters on
board we wanted to be able to capture
the motion of a boat across multiple
characters simultaneously and we for the
first time had the space to be able to
to construct a proper rig for this so we
had a platform which could be moved in
any number of ways to create that kind
of pitch in your own role that you would
get on the ocean and we got our actors
up onto this boat and captured scene
with highways and a storm and we got
incredible data from really really
amazing
being able to do that in our own
basement is really important for how
quickly we want to iterate on that data
and get it into engine and see what it
looks like you know we can always come
back and do things again and we don't
have to worry about scheduling or
finding performers or anything like that
that you might need to worry about in a
normal kind of third-party shoot
the most important part of my role is to
make sure that story gets told
and having these wonderful actors we're
working with
bring their talents to bear on these
characters has been such an amazing
experience
foreign
[Music]